as I stated earlier I have voluntarily
appeared in front of Congress on three
separate occasions and spoken to members
of the special counsels office from
multiple hours I will continue to be
forthright forthright and cooperative
and I will be as sincere in my answers
as this committee is and its questions
thank you for your testimony we will now
proceed under the five-minute rule with
questions at the completion of the
members questions pursuant to the
Chairman's September 12 2009 tene
resolution 4 investigative procedures
and pursuant to a notice this will be
followed by one hour of staff
questioning equally divided by the
majority and the minority I will begin
by recognizing myself for five minutes
mr. Lewandowski we received a letter
from the White House just yesterday that
they will not let you answer any
questions beyond what you told the
special counsel and was publicly
released the White House's instruction
to you is based on a bogus claim of
executive privilege even though you did
not work a single day for the
administration let alone in the
executive branch my colleague is he
going to get into the specific invents
in detail but I'm especially troubled by
the president's attempt to obstruct
Congress's investigation and prevent the
American people from learning the truth
about what he's done and I want to ask
you questions relevant to that issue mr.
Lewandowski is a correct that is
reported in the Mullen report on June 19
2017 you met alone in the Oval Office
with the president
I said is there a book and page number
you can reference me to please
I don't have a copy of the report in
front of me volume 2 page 90 but I
simply ask you is it correct that as
reported in the Muller report on June
19th 2017 you met alone in the Oval
Office with the president could you read
the exact language of the report sir I
don't have it available to me I don't
think I need to do that and I have a
limited time did you meet alone with the
president that date Kyra I'd like you to
refresh my memory by providing a copy of
the report so I can follow along hey you
don't have a copy with I don't have a
copy of the report congressman the
Chairman I request that the clock be
stopped while this charade is sorted out
yes okay I'm sorry Congress what page
was it the clock should have been
stopped and should remain stump page not
page 90 volume 2 ok which paragraph sir
I don't have it in front of me I'd like
a reference sir so I can follow along
and what you're asking do you not have
an independent recollection of whether
you met with the President on that date
congra I'm just trying to find in the
mall report where it states that well
you have it in front of you I gave you
the president the page number yeah we're
on page 90 is it sir mr. chairman you
guys start the clock miss no I don't
have to start the clock what he's
filibuster me bottom of page 9
filibustering is a big item across the
hall and this is actual questions being
done mr. chairman the point of
parliamentary inquiry mr. chairman
that's not a gentleman say disappointed
parliamentary inquiry mr. chairman is it
appropriate for a witness to refuse to
answer a question and instead demand
that we reference and point him to the
ask that that mullah report be closed
and the witness be directed to answer
the question
the answer it is not appropriate but
it's on the bottom two lines of that
page
and like is going [ __ ] as far now
there's a point of point of order
when will the clocks start mr. chairman
once the questions I ask mr. chairman
the clock should start under overview
second line parliamentary inquiry mr.
chairman the gentleman the whelen of
order witness has the time and waters a
question the witness orders arrive that
a point of order overrides that mr.
chairman and you know that it's genuine
with state his point of order
one of orders once the question has been
asked in reference properly to the
witness to answer the question the clock
should start it cannot be held while you
and your counsel go over notes the
gentleman is correct the jitney clock
will start and the question the witness
will answer the question without further
delay yes I see that in the report thank
you during that meeting did you tell the
special counsel that the president quote
asks you to deliver a message to
sessions who was then the Attorney
General the United States
page 91
they ask you a question sir I'm looking
for that reference on page 91
congressman do you not have an
independent recollection no I'm looking
mr. Harrison I'm trying to adhere to the
White House's request I answer questions
that have provided in the malla report
only so I'm trying to reference that
report directly about your question
congressman were you a White House
employee at that time no congressman
and if did you have okay you did not
hold any position in the government
whatsoever did you correct now I was
sitting behind you a counsel for the
White House correct that's my
understanding you understand those
lawyers actually work for the president
at the White House I believe that
accurate nevertheless the president's
lawyers have told you not to answer any
question by this committee other than
what has already been disclosed and the
special counsels report is that correct
Connor fine I have to read from the
letter that the White House provided the
committee if that would help clarify
would you like me do that congressman no
I'd like you to answer the question have
you been directed congressman I've never
spoken to any members of the White House
counsel's office than saying hello about
15 seconds ago did you were directed by
letter congressman I was provided a
letter that I believe this committee was
assigned it says as explained below
mr. lewandowski's conversation with the
President and with senior advisors to
the president are protected from
disclosure by long-standing long settled
principles protecting executive branch
confidentiality interests and as a
result the White House is directing mr.
Lewandowski not to provide information
about such communications as young
information providing the portion to the
report take that as a yes never the and
the basis for that direction is a claim
of executive privilege is that correct
I can read again congressman the answer
is you know you're not answering the
question
but we've already established that you
were never employed by the White House
of the executive branch that is correct
I have never been employed by the
executive branch sir did you ask the
White House counsel's to be here
congressman as I just reiterated I've
never spoken to anyone the White House
counsel's office there's no was it your
idea for you not to answer questions
based on the claim of executive
privileged I can reiterate I didn't ask
I've never had a conversation with some
from the White House counsel's office
regarding was not Europe so was your
idea not there I have never had a
conversation with some from the White
House counselors right not to answer
these questions the base of executive
privilege yes or no congressman I can
only go by the letter that was provided
was not my idea to provide this letter
not your idea
did you ever suggest to the President or
anyone else that you thought your
communications with him were official
White House communications Congress from
the White House is directed not I not
disclose the substance of any
discussions with the prisoners advisers
to protect executive branch
confidentiality and I recognize this is
not my privilege but I am respecting the
White House's decision let me ask you
some questions about your relationship
with the president after he assumed
office how many times does the president
asked you to meet him in the White House
the White House's director and not
disclose the substance of memories did
you meet with the president alone in the
White House in 2017 I don't know the
answer to that how many times did he
direct you to deliver a message to a
member of his cabinet the White House is
direct I had not disclosed the substance
of any discussions with the president
did he ever discuss with you any
concerns that he may have committed a
criminal offense the White House has
directed not disclosed the substance of
any discussions with the President or
his advisors to protect executive branch
confidentiality I recognize this is not
my privilege I'm gonna make a point of
order
pursuant to Clause 2 j2a of rule 1 1111
that the gentleman is out of order he
has exceeded the time limit under the
five-minute rule I will enforce the
tight of these time limit under the
five-minute I challenge the very I
challenge the ruling the chair the chant
the ruling of the chair is challenged
all those in favor of overriding the
rule the chair will say I oppose no no
roll call votes have it roll call is
asked the clerk will quote where's the
clerk will call the roll
yes mr. Nadler question is Willie with a
really the question is will the ruling
of the chair be overruled my vote is no
mr. Nadler votes no mr. Laughlin
miss Jackson Lee miss Jackson Lee votes
no mr. Cohen mr. Cohen votes no mr.
johnson of georgia mr. johnson of
georgia votes no mr. Deutsch mr. Deutsch
votes no miss miss bass votes no mr.
Richmond mr. Jeffries
mr. Jeffries votes no mr. Cicilline mr.
Cicilline votes no mr. suave oh no mr.
suave all votes no mr. Liu mr. Luo votes
no mr. Raskin mr. Raskin votes no mr.
Chia Paul miss Jaya Paul votes no mr.
Mike's miss Demings votes no mr. ko
mr. Correia votes no mr. kalin miss
Scanlon votes no mr. SIA no miss Garcia
votes no mr. Nagus mr. Nguyen Oh miss
Macbeth mr. Stanton
no mr. Stanton votes no mr. Deane no
miss Deane votes no mr. Moo cárcel
Powell miss Escobar mr. Collins mr.
Collins votes aye
mr. Sensenbrenner mr. Chabot mr. Chabot
votes aye mr. gohmert mr. Jordan mr.
Jordan votes yes mr. buck mr. Radcliffe
mr. Radcliffe votes yes miss Roby mr.
gates
mr. gates votes aye mr. Johnson of
Louisiana mr. Johnson of Louisiana votes
aye mr. Biggs
mr. Riggs votes aye mr. McLintock mr.
McLintock votes aye miss let's go miss
let's go votes aye mr. eshton thaller
mr. Kline mr. Kline votes aye mr.
Armstrong mr. Armstrong votes yes mr.
stouby mr. Stu V votes yes
is everyone voted who wishes to vote
good
Madame clerk mr. buck you are not
recorded mr. buck votes yes is anyone
else the clerk will report
mr. chairman there are 13 eyes and 19
nose mr. chairman yeah mr. chairman one
of order mr. chairman it says the
Chairman is refused gentleman is not
recognized I will be the the point of
order is sustained mr. Chairman I am
very troubled that the White House
Counsel sitting behind you are
preventing you from answering these very
basic questions that go to the heart of
the president's conduct we are investors
chairman I have a motion not mr.
Connolly ocean you will wait for the
motion till I finish this one of order
they're not not only one of order has
got to be recognized not in the middle
yes it does the motion is to it since
the chairman is not following the house
rules I move to adjourn
motion is to adjourn the most point of
parliamentary inquiry mr. chairman ocean
to adjourn state if the Republicans on
this committee are successful in this
motion to adjourn does that mean there
will be no hearing and the American
people will not hear from mr.
Lewandowski about his efforts to
obstruct justice yes that's exactly what
it man that's one it also could read
they could read to three two oh she's
already done I've appointed elementary
inquiry the motion is not debatable as
many as are in favor the motion to have
emotional parliamentary many are in
favor mr. Cicilline gets recognized for
recognized a table as many as are in
favor the motion to adjourn say aye
opposed no in the opinion of the chair
the noes have it
we will roll call is requested the
question is on the motion to adjourn the
clerk will call the roll
mr. Nadler no mr. Nadler votes no mr.
Frane miss Jackson Lee
miss Jackson Lee votes no mr. Cohen mr.
Cohen votes no mr johnson of georgia mr.
johnson of georgia votes no mr. Deutsch
mr. Deutsch votes no miss miss bass
votes no mr. Richmond mr. Jeffries mr.
Jeffries votes no mr. Cicilline no mr.
Cicilline votes no mr. swallow no mr.
suavo votes no mr. Leu mr. Leu votes no
mr. Raskin mr. Raskin votes no mr. Chia
Paul miss jayapal votes no mr. menges
miss Demings votes no mr. Correa mr.
Correia votes no mr. Allen miss Scanlon
votes no mr. SIA no
miss Garcia votes no mr. Magoo's mr.
Nguyen Oh miss Macbeth mr. Stanton
mr. Stanton votes no misty no no miss
Deane votes no missus misma carcel
Powell miss Escobar mr. Collins mr.
Collins both sigh mr. Sensenbrenner mr.
Chabot mr. Chabot both sigh mr. gohmert
mr. Jordan mr. Jordan votes aye
mr. buck mr. Radcliffe mr. Radcliffe
votes yes miss Roby mr. gates
mr. gates votes aye mr. Johnson of
Louisiana mr. Johnson of Louisiana votes
aye
mr. baek's mr. baek's votes aye mr.
McLintock mr. McLintock votes aye miss
let's go miss let's go votes aye mr.
Rushton thaller mr. Kline uh mr. Kline
votes aye mr. Armstrong mr. Armstrong
votes yes mr. Stu be mr. Snoopy votes
yes
mr. chairman there are 12 eyes and 19
nose the motion to adjourn is not
adopted and I will finish what I was
saying
I am very troubled at the White House
Council sitting behind you are
preventing you from answering these very
basic questions that go to the heart of
the president's conduct we are
investigating not only we are not a
government employee but these questions
are about the president's efforts to
interfere with a criminal investigation
of himself and have nothing to do with
official government business this is
clearly just part of the president's
continued attempt to cover up his
actions he is obstructing our
congressional investigation by
preventing you from telling the American
people the truth about his misconduct he
will not succeed and we will not be
deterred I now recognize the gentleman
from Georgia for his opening questions
Thank You mr. chairman
this past few minutes was totally
avoidable and also very frustrating and
since that is also now raised from our
perspective the question of the
privilege of the rules of the house
which could be discussed on the floor
and probably will be and possibly just
the blatant running over of House Rules
my concern is ethics violations as well
this has got to be run in a different
way so at this point mr. Lewandowski you
have testified before Congress multiple
times over the past couple years correct
yes
correct me if I'm wrong you've already
trust-fund twice twice before the house
Intel committee correct yes
how long was those sessions I think the
first session was about seven hours and
the second session was maybe four hours
you've also testified for Senate Intel
correct yes
about how long was that as about eight
hours you've also testified before the
special counsel I was correct yes how
many times two separate occasions and
four about how long probably 15 to 16
hours okay and those were voluntarily
correct yes sir
okay so there was really and you were
agreed to come here voluntarily as well
correct today I did there was no need
for a fault for a basically a flawed
subpoena to be issued to you correct
correct okay and I want to know that our
staff and many of our members have read
the full FBI summary of your testimony
because everyone in this committee has
access to your special counsel interview
summary for months have you had the
opportunity to review the eff past
summaries
preparation for the bath no sir which
goes to the point about why he won't be
able to remember so many details outside
the what is specifically written in the
molar report and that something needs to
be made aware of were you giving any
guidelines by the Democrats on the
topics or subjects of your questions
today not to the best of my recollection
yeah you know that is a problem we seem
to have here is basically war to say is
over broad subpoenas around here there's
I mean we could have talked today about
your favorite football team
I'm not patriots matrix so you're pretty
happy right now right tons a winner
again the problem we have here is we
don't follow procedure because if he
gets in the way of a good story we don't
like it around here so we'll do whatever
we want including Burke House Rules to
do that as we go forward in any of the
times that you've had today especially
not being questioned you have cited in
your opening saying that you plan to
answer as best you possibly can is that
correct yes sir but you also is a
certain point in time realized that
being having testified so many times in
this various issues that we have that
there are certain things you know is
does that concern you having to keep
coming back and back again without
having proper reference if somebody was
to if as you said earlier I want to know
the reference in what you're speaking to
would that be a problem to you well sir
I think my memory obviously two events
which transpired more than two years ago
was clearer the first time I testify to
because it was a year and a half ago on
many occasions or longer so if I can
have a specific reference of something
I'd be happy to have that so it's not
dilatory from your opinion you just want
to make sure that you give an accurate
seeing how you've also already testified
on these issues many times before
correct yes sir so doing plot otherwise
is basically you know in many ways
taking a shot at your testimony here
correct it is okay when you worked on
the Trump campaign you said this early I
just want it to be stated again because
we've had these hearings here in the the
Judiciary Committee didn't seem to take
but we'll try again did you engage in
collusion coordination or conspiracy
with the Russians never did you observe
anyone else doing that no sir
okay when we look at what's going on
here today
I think the concern that we have and
many of us on this side is we have a
narratives failed the failed narrative
is continued you're being asked to come
in here and do something that you've
done many times over that this whole
committee has seen
than what you're looking for if you're
following the premise of what the
Chairman says that the majority is
looking for is that they're finding a
reason to try and appease the president
I've already said they they have found
17 of them at least have publicly said
they found a reason which really don't
have to you know any further but they
can't get the more on the floor to do
this so this is dragging this out so
this wasn't asking I would encourage you
you know to answer the questions fully
as you said you would do you voluntarily
come here even though that we decided to
throw a flawed subpoena at you and the
others as well and I think as we go
forward here we'll see how this actually
moves forward but this is concerning to
me mr. chairman I'm gonna take this for
the for the moment it's okay to try and
get your stuff out it's okay to be
frustrated but it's also not okay to
overrun House Rules the five-minute rule
is a house rule it's not a committee
rule and it's not for up for
interpretation by the Chairman whatever
it feels like it wouldn't be if I was
the chairman or you're the chairman
that's not debatable and you may not
have got your last question in but we've
already discussed it we're gonna have a
lot more discussion here in a little
while on staff questioning but there's
there's plenty of time to get that last
little question that you didn't get
asked to somebody else but is it worth
breaking the house rules I know some of
the audience don't care and some of the
majority don't care but at the end of
the day you're accusing a president of
very high issues did we got a look at
you're accusing him and dragging through
in this committee for eight months we're
doing this so I think following
procedures is something that you
actually have to look at because your
idea is not really water mr. chairman
the time is expired
I mean if he wishes he doesn't wish
you
good morning mr. Lewandowski I'm giving
unquestioning youth right now thank you
the president asked you who had no role
at all in the White House to deliver
that message to attorney General
Sessions the president could have just
picked up the phone himself at any time
and called the Attorney General the
president also had a full staff of
executive employees right down the hall
so this made me wonder if the president
thought what he was doing was legal why
didn't he just pick up the phone and
call the Attorney General sessions or
why not ask any member of his staff who
worked right down the hall to deliver a
message it is clear to me that the
reason he went to you mr. Lewandowski is
because everyone said no so I'm going to
ask you about that
two days before meeting you the
president had called white House Counsel
McGann at home on a Saturday to fire the
pistol counsel saying and you can see
that on the screen mala has to go call
me back when you do it plain and simple
but McGann refused when the president
asks you to deliver that message did he
the president tell you that two days
before your meeting his White House
Counsel have refused to fire the special
counsel volume 1186 is where you'll find
that language volume 2 volume 2 when the
president answer did you hear the
question I'm trying to repeat the
question class president asked you to
deliver that message did he the
president tell you that two days before
your meeting his White House Counsel had
refused to fire the special counsel the
White House has to rush mean that I did
not disclose the substance any
conversations with the PO whether the
president told you he called his counsel
at home on Saturday to remove on he said
you removed the special counsel his
counsel said no the president had also
personally called sessions at home and
asked him to Unruh cues himself and
oversee the special counsels
investigation and sessions said no when
the president asks you to deliver his
message to sessions did the president
tell you
that sessions had already said no volume
to one page 107 again Congress when I
recognize that the privilege is not mine
but I've been asked by the White House
to understand I'd be happy to answer
your question or you can just have a
conversation by yourself but if you'd
like to ask me a question I'll be happy
I'm just going to continue the reason is
they don't ask me a question for one
team at a time this is a house to
Detroit not a house party just ask me a
question give me the opportunity to
answer your question campaign the
special counts was investigating I'd
like my time restored please of his
interruption
so he was a witness to the special
counselors investigation for that reason
session said publicly that federal law
prohibited his involvement in the
special counselors investigation
here's a quote from the report from
volume two pages 49 to 50 which is on
the screen you can read that yes or no
did the president tell you that the
Attorney General was legally not allowed
to take any part in a special counsels
investigation when he asked you to
deliver him a note about that very
investigation did the president tell you
that
what you've just read it on the screen
congressman
you need to look at the screen
yes or no read the screen you're welcome
to read it congresswoman you're welcome
to be stalling and I'm not going to
stall you either answer the question yes
or no counterspell take the same
privileges imagine other members all you
that nobody at the White House was
supposed to even contact the Attorney
General about the investigation that you
can answer yes or no I will not disclose
any conversations I've had with the
president Congress well again you are
obviously here to block any reasonable
inquiry into the truth or not of this
administration the White House Counsel
quote shortly after sessions announces
recusal directed that sessions should
not be contacted about the Special
Counsel investigation in fact the White
House counsel's internal notes state no
contact with sessions and no
communication serious about instruction
can you read that I just said it can you
read that did you hear me yes is there a
question yes did the president tell you
his White House Counsel told him no
contact with sessions because of serious
concerns of obstruction when he asked
you to deliver a message to sessions I'm
respecting the executive branch
privilege of confidentiality and I will
recognize that this time let me just say
that you knew did you know the president
was putting you at risk when he asked
you to deliver a message to the Attorney
General
I want to be very clear the president
knew what he was doing was wrong because
everyone else had already said no he
called his White House Counsel to fire
the special counsel McGann said no he
called the Attorney General to ask him
to Unruh Cuse himself from the special
counsels investigation session said no
his White House Counsel said there
should be no contact with session
because of his refusal so what does the
president do he calls you in to do what
everyone else wouldn't do he called you
in to do his dirty work in secret
because he knew it was wrong well we
will expose the truth I mean President
can hide behind you any longer I may be
here to be telling the truth
general house key
we'll set you - people I yield back the
time of the gentlelady has expired the
witness may answer the question I don't
believe there was a question congressman
very well yes there was
could you repeat the question I didn't
hear it I'll be happy to repeat the just
a rant I'll be hearing to be gentle
ladies time has expired
you know the attorney general the chair
accuse the gentleman from Ohio mr.
Chabot is recognized
Thank You mr. chairman mr. Lewandowski
thank you for appearing this afternoon
to testify before this committee I
understand that you've spent many hours
testifying voluntarily before Congress
over the last few years isn't that
correct
it isn't and have you had to hire and
retain counsel to represent you for all
the investigations that you've had to
endure simply because you served as the
president's campaign manager yes sir
that's unfortunate because you didn't
solicit or receive assistance from the
Russians did you no sir are you an agent
working on behalf of the Russian
government no sir as a close friend and
advisor of the president you don't
believe that the president is working on
behalf of the Russian do you absolutely
not and to your knowledge there is no
effort on the part of the President to
intentionally obstruct justice is there
no sir thank you and yet again coming
here to tell this committee what we
special counsel Moeller and the American
public already know the president Trump
did not collude with the Russians nor
did he obstruct justice that's not to
say that the Russians weren't trying to
interfere and influence our 2016
presidential elections it's clear that
they were by sending fake texts and
operating fake facebook pages and
holding fake rallies all in an effort to
try to influence the outcome of the
election Democrats want to ignore all of
the real evidence of Russian
interference and hold this fake
impeachment
because it happened under a different
presidents watch this all happened under
President Obama's watch isn't that
correct yes sir
and it was the Obama administration that
failed to protect us from the Russian
interference and influence in our
election isn't that also true yes
president Trump wasn't president he
wasn't the one that failed to protect
the country
if anybody failed it was the Obama
administration is that right yes it is
I've said it before and I'll say it
again we're wasting valuable committee
time engaging in this impeachment
investigation the fact of the matter is
one thing this committee could be doing
is to question inspector general
Horowitz concerning the bias against the
president at the origins of the Russian
investigation we could be questioning
Horowitz about his recent report how
then FBI director Comey mishandled
Department memos this committee has such
a rich history his jurisdiction over a
whole lot of very significant things
we're spending our time on this fake
impeachment but we could be focused on
something that really matters like
immigration asylum we have hundreds of
thousands of people that have entered
our southern border generally they're
brought up either individually or in
groups caravans usually oftentimes
connected with cartels cartels make a
lot of money when they come up here
they're told the magic words come across
the border they say that they're in fear
and come right into our country and we
put them on a on a bus or on a plane
that are sent to communities all across
the country that's something this
committee should be working in a
bipartisan manner to do something about
opioids we have about 70,000 Americans
who lost their lives to opioids last
year that's something in the
jurisdiction of this committee yet we do
virtually nothing about in this
committee balanced budget amendment it's
something I've introduced in this
Congress we got a 22 trillion dollar
debt hanging over our head yet we do
nothing in this committee about
attempting to actually pass something
that would make us balance the budget
every year like all our
States have to do so finally I just want
to thank you again mr. Lewandowski for
appearing at today's hearing perhaps
your testimony today will finally
convince Democrats that there are much
more important things that this
committee could be spending our time on
rather than continuing to pursue this
fake impeachment a faux impeachment the
bottom line is they don't have the votes
in the house to move forward to or the
house to vote for this committee to open
up an impeachment inquiry they don't
think the votes some of the Democrats
went about for it some of the Democrats
would vote against it but they don't
have the votes so what they do is they
spend valuable committee time that we
could be spending on other important
things on this fake fo impeachment and
it's a shame because this committee
could be doing so much more on behalf of
the American people with that I yield
back mr. chairman point of parliamentary
inquiry who state-supported
general no estate is point of
parliamentary inquiry mr. chairman and
the witness just answered a long line of
questions from the gentleman from Ohio
about whether Donald Trump had colluded
with the Russians and about the origins
of the Muller investigation and so on
but he never testified as to any of
those things before special counsel
Muller can he now continue to invoke
this White House rationale that he's
confined to the four corners of the
Muller report when he's gone way beyond
it in his responses to the questioning
from the gentleman from Ohio the
regardless of whether he went beyond the
four corners of the Moller report and
the answers that he gave to the last to
the last questioner regardless of that
and I'm glad to hear is the he favors
the Patriots even though that's not in
the Marlin report but regardless of the
long series of answers that he gave
irrelevant that weren't in the Moller
report the claim of privilege made by
the witness is improper for the reasons
set forth in our letter today to the
White House and to the witnesses counsel
that said I will take the claim of
privilege under advisement mr. chairman
parliamentary inquiry the gentleman will
state his poem did you actually answer
his Paul
your inquiry because it was a statement
not a parliamentary inquiry you just
sort of skipped on the executive
privilege here at least their knowledge
that it was not a parliamentary inquiry
the gentleman stated the parliamentary
inquiry he didn't arrive at a statement
I answered his parliamentary inquiry the
general the gentleman from Tennessee is
recognized Thank You mr. chair mr.
Lewandowski has been made clear here you
were not an employee and you met it at
the White House
you had no w2 you had no card you had
nothing you were not an employee and you
weren't a policeman at one time so you
know something about the law and about
following the law didn't you think it
was a little strange that the president
would sit down with you one-on-one and
ask you to do something that you knew
was against the law did that strike you
as strange I disagree with the premise
of your question congressman you weren't
a policeman I didn't I didn't think the
president asked me to do anything
illegal you didn't think it would have
been illegal for you to ask mr. sessions
to drop the investigation and to just go
on to future presidents and omit
everything with this president no al
Italian free we're gonna start with the
next one about colluding with Russia you
didn't think that was illegal to
obstruct justice
congressman the prisoners ask me
anything illegal obviously you never
been a judge and won't be one all these
people asked if he gave you dictation he
dictated to you a message to give
sessions had you ever been a secretary
for the president before and taking
dictation or shorthand many times oh so
we got your qualifications now you were
a secretary could it could but he asked
you outside of White House channels and
that's what Muller wrote that this was
outside of White House channels could it
have been he asked you to get the
message to sessions because he thought
you would do whatever he asked even if
it was illegal or immoral just like your
former boss Bob ney who said you were an
implementer news reports called you the
president's quote enforcer USA Today
said lewandowski's background is largely
as a truck guy and not so much as a
strategist not a campaign manager but as
a right-hand man a body man and an
enforcer and Esquire went further and
said the one time campaign manager for
Donald Trump's has the traits of an
enforcer and the conflict resolution
skills to match and you have have you've
even scribed yourself in your book let
Trump be Trump you said we were fine
with whatever role the president wanted
us to play and Donald Trump's army there
were only loyal soldiers there were no
moral Orel soldiers your previous boss
Bob ney was convicted of corruption and
lying to authorities in the jack abraham
scandal you were fired from Americans
for Prosperity after being accused of
fraud voter fraud you are now involved
in this either you were willing to break
the law for politics and mr. Trump are
you're some kind of a Forrest Gump
relating to corruption so maybe let me
ask you this did the president pick you
his enforcer he thought you would play
whatever role he wanted because it was
illegal is that possibly why he chose
you to take this message to sessions
that'd be a question for the president
congressman well Donald Trump was right
though first the White House Counsel Don
Magan refused to fire the special
counsel mr. McGann showed principle and
character and refused to do what he knew
would be in the illegal act then
attorney General Sessions who had
recused himself was asked to Unruh Cuse
himself but attorney general sessions
also did the right thing and he said I'm
not going to Unruh cues myself because I
have a
conflict because I did was involved the
campaign and do some things can't do it
then the White House account counsel
advised the president not even to
contact sessions but you his loyal
soldier would do it you were different
than sessions and began Trump could
depend on you you did not ask any
questions you were a loyal soldier you
just wrote down the message and agreed
to deliver it that's what he thought you
took the dictation you gave it the hope
Hicks yeah it's her to type it up for
you not that you couldn't have done it
yourself I'm sure and then ask somebody
else to deliver the message to sessions
when you decided not to Donald Trump
talk to you outside normal channels so
there'd be no record of anything that he
asked you to do to obstruct justice
nothing to do with that at all the
president knew what he was doing was
wrong mr. sessions knew what he was
doing is wrong mr. McGann knew he's
doing wrong you seem to me up the only
person didn't think was wrong but mr.
Trump was wrong cuz at the last minute
you got cold feet you chickened out
the president's trust was misplaced you
decided not to do what you told the
president you were gonna do and you
handed it off to somebody else did you
realize at some point that mr. ney your
former boss got involved in criminal
problems and went to prison and maybe
you were gonna be the next one did that
cross your mind did you ever think about
bob ney situation to go into prison
congressman a congressman so we're clear
went to jail many years after I left his
employment I'm sure you're gonna clarify
that for the record and you were his
employee and you were had great respect
for him but you learned from that I'm
asking did you learn from his experience
and realized that what you were asked to
do was illegal and you didn't want to
follow the same trail as Bob ney and end
up in prison I wasn't asked so anything
illegal congressman well the public will
determine that this has been more
obstruction of Congress by this
administration and you've followed their
instructions and you're doing just
exactly what they thought you'd do
you're a loyal soldier except you didn't
follow Trump's instructions you
chickened out at the last minute you got
cold feet I yield back the balance of my
time
the gentleman yields back the gentleman
from Ohio Thank You mr. chairman mr.
Lewandowski you ran president Trump's
campaign between January 2015 and June
2016 is that right yeah
you're at the helm of the campaign when
President Trump secured the Republican
nomination yes pretty good campaign you
ran thank you
I mean you beat what 17 18 different
opponents senators governors some good
senators of course you had a pretty good
candidate the best pretty good candidate
I think it's done a great job as
president of the United States after you
left the campaign I think you left in
June of 2016 after you left the head of
the campaign were you still involved
with the campaign throughout the rest of
the election all the way up through
November 8th 2016 yes in that entire
time so you were part of the campaign
operation at some level or another from
January 2015 to November 8 2016 during
that entire time do you guys ever work
with Russia to impact the election no
and you know what's interesting mr.
Lewandowski when Jim Comey was asked
that same question sitting at that same
table he gave the same answer
Bob Muller was asked that same question
sitting at that same table he gave the
same answer falsely accused the
president is falsely accused of
colluding with a foreign state to impact
the election Jim Comey when we deposed
him at that very table said after 10
months of investigation we didn't have a
thing Bob Mulligan's name special
counsel he wastes 30 million dollars of
taxpayer money 22 month investigation he
sits at that table just a few weeks ago
and gives the same darn answer but these
guys over here they don't care they
don't care they don't want to get to
what mr. Chabot said they don't want to
figure out how the false accusation
happened they just want to drag people
in front of this committee and keep
trying to find some way they can go
after the president let's go back to the
process that the ranking member raised
did you testify in front of the Senate
Intel committee in 2017 yes you testify
in front of the House Intelligence
Committee in 2017 yes and you went
before the special counsel and answered
his questions in 2018 is that right
it is and you did that all voluntarily
yes no subpoena no sir said I'm willing
to comply give answers answer all the
questions you got yes I think in your
opening statement you said 20 some went
to how many hours did you set
for those various committees more than
20 more than 20 hours and for this
committee did you get a letter from this
committee back in March asking you to
comply with certain document requests
that chairman Adler wanted a half I
believe so yes
and you and your legal team complied
with that yes sir and then on June 24th
you got another letter is that right yes
June 24th of this year you got another
letter asking you to do an interview a
transcribed interview in front of the
committee and your lawyer contacted
chairman Adler and said we'd be happy to
do that is that right yes they give us
some dates we'll come in we'll be happy
to sit for an interview that's right
what happened next
next about five weeks ago the committee
issued subpoena for my appearance so
you're willing to come voluntarily just
like you did with Senate Intel house
Intel just like you did for Bob Muller
for the special counsel 20-some hours
you will do that all you complied with
when they asked you for certain
documents and then when they wanted to
come in for an interview you said all
right sure we'll do it they hit with the
subpoena correct and then they start
calling you names saying close up that
book answer the question start treating
you this way kind of interesting they're
the ones that started it they're the one
just left you with the subpoena when you
were willing to come here voluntarily I
was and then they then then the question
what the demeanor you bring here today I
mean first they changed the rules last
week in the middle of the Congress
change the rules of the committee in the
middle of the game and then today
they're not even going to follow the
rules because the rules that changed
last week talk about staff asking
questions at the end after members are
done we got this whole issue with
consultants so this maybe we would be
better served if we did exactly what mr.
Chabot said maybe we would be better
served as the House Judiciary Committee
if we actually focused on how this whole
false accusation started in the first
place what do you think mr. Lewandowski
I think it'd be a great idea great it
may be maybe the American people would
be better served then spending more time
investigating something that's already
had 32 months of investigation from both
Jim combing the FBI and Bob Muller and
Special Counsel maybe we would do that
you know a great place to start a great
place to start mr. chairman
ask you about this one we could go today
great place to start be the Inspector
General's report that was issued just
three weeks ago the scathing report
about Jim Comey that'd be a nice place
to start but when I asked the Chairman
when we might have an opportunity to
question mr. Horowitz he said I don't
know I haven't thought about that of
course you haven't thought about that
too busy trying to impeach the president
too busy slapping subpoenas on Corey
Lewandowski of course you haven't
thought about that's what the committee
should be focused on I yield back
gentleman yields back the gentleman from
Georgia Thank You mr. chairman mr.
Lewandowski you are about like a fish
being cleaned with a spoon it's very
hard to get an answer out of you but let
me ask you this sir based on the
president's past statements everybody
knows that the president does not like
for anybody to take notes when he's
talking in fact he has lawyers not to
take official notes and you're aware of
that correct
I'm aware of the public account sir all
right fair enough and but when the
president met with you in the Oval
Office one-on-one on June 19th 2017 to
dictate a message to attorney general
Jeff Sessions he told you to quote write
this down isn't that correct attacker
and it was just you and the president in
that meeting correct it was and you knew
that you needed to write down as fast as
possible what the president was telling
you so that you could make sure to
capture the content of what he was
telling you correctly correct I don't
know the speed of writing was a criteria
but I tried to capture it to the best of
my ability congressman thank you sir and
he dictated to you exactly what he
wanted you to put into the mouth of
attorney general Jeff Sessions correct
I believe he asked me to deliver a
message for Jeff to consider delivering
himself and it was a message that he
intended for Jeff meaning Jeff sessions
to deliver out loud and publicly he
wanted the public to know what he was
saying but he wanted Jeff to say it
correctly I believe the mall report
accurately depicts that and mr.
Lewandowski we've projected on the on
the screen the message that the
president dictated to you that he wanted
you to deliver to the Attorney General
it's on the screen and I'd like for you
to read the first two sentences if you
would entertain that Oh as director
Muller stated when asked to read from
the report and I quote I would be happy
to have you read it congressman well
would you prefer for me to read it
instead of you please okay it says I
know that I recused myself from certain
things having to do with specific areas
but our POTUS is being treated very
unfairly that's what he told you to
write down and that's what you wrote
down and I'll continue he said he
shouldn't have a special prosecutor
counsel because he hasn't done anything
wrong
yeah that's what he wanted you to
deliver to attorney general Jeff
Sessions correct I believe that's an
accurate representation and he wanted
you to deliver it to Jeff so that Jeff
could say it to the people right I
believe so
and you felt kind of squeamish like a
like that fish that you are trying to be
right now being scaled you felt a little
squeamish about delivering that message
correct no sir
well why didn't you why did it take you
so long and you never even delivered it
correct I never delivered the message
yeah you chickened out I went on
vacation you wouldn't have education and
so you put the you put the message in
the safe in your safe in your home for
safekeeping correct before you went on
vacation I took my kids to the beach
congressman that's more of a priority
Trump was hounding you about when are
you gonna deliver that message correct
completely inaccurate congressman well
he asked you about it a few times didn't
he
no he did not he'd never asked you
whether or not you had delivered that
message not on multiple occasions now
you one occasion okay he did mention it
on one occasion to you I don't know if
that's in the report sir yeah and you
and you told him that yeah I'm gonna get
around to it I'm gonna deliver it
correct I'd have to see the reference to
the malla report without it it's in the
report and every direct me to the
booking page like that I don't need to
waste any time with that but let me tell
you something the next three sentences
after those first two would you read
those please you're welcome to
congressman okay he said he shouldn't
have a special cuts or a prosecutor or
counsel because he hasn't done anything
wrong I was on the campaign with him for
nine months there were no Russians
involved with him I know it for a fact
because I was there now the president
wanted Attorney General to say that but
you didn't deliver the message and you
knew that Attorney General Sessions had
recused himself at that time and since
he had recused himself you knew that it
would have been against the law for him
to comment in any way on that
investigation isn't that right I did not
know that you did not know that you did
not know that correct the time of the
gentleman has expired the gentleman from
Colorado
thank you for putting up with the
harassment that you're putting up with
right now according to the Alliance for
securing democracy Russia interfered in
the elections of Belarus Bulgaria Canada
Cyprus the Czech Republic Denmark
Estonia Finland France Georgia Germany
Hungary Italy Latvia Lithuania Macedonia
Moldova Montenegro Norway Poland
Portugal Spain Sweden turkey United
Kingdom Ukraine and the United States
they specifically targeted the Scottish
independence vote the brexit vote and
Angela Merkel despite knowledge of these
kinds of election threats the Obama
administration sat idly by instead of
warning the Trump campaign Loretta
Lynch's DOJ and James commis FBI used
secret surveillance to spy on members of
the Trump campaign all while allowing
election interference to occur why isn't
this hearing focused on holding DOJ and
FBI leadership accountable for this kind
of terrible malfeasance and lack of
judgment what was Putin's Open ultimate
goal Clint Watts a former FBI agent and
counterterrorism specialists said it is
to attack and undermine democracy he
said the goal is to leave voters feeling
as if quote either the institutions are
corrupt or you can't trust the vote end
of quote
this is the kind of classic
disinformation campaign that the KGB
runs and as we all know Vladimir Putin
was a former leader of the KGB in 2016
Putin's goal could have been very simple
divide the American electorate sow seeds
of distrust make it impossible for
whoever won our election to govern with
America weakened at home we would be
weakened on the international stage
Putin wins with a weakened America
regardless of who won the election this
is the kind of approach that has been
used by the Communists in Russia for
nearly a century after overthrowing
russian tsar nicholas ii in 1917
Vladimir Putin Vladimir Lenin I'm sorry
different Vladimir and the Communists
utilized Western journalists as
propaganda tools to defend communism New
York Times journalist John Reid for
example defended the Bolsheviks
advocating against American intervention
Lenin used even the term useful idiot
to describe how leftist leaning
communist sympathizing Americans could
be easily tricked and used to help the
Russians for the past three years
Democrats have focused on undermining
America's president instead of working
with President Trump and Republicans in
Congress to harden our election defenses
I think there would be broad bipartisan
support that we need to prevent future
election meddling the Mullah report
makes clear that President Trump wanted
to focus on protecting our democracy
from future attacks so I have one
question mr. Lewandowski it's clear that
Putin attacked America with the goal of
dividing the American people and today's
hearing is being held for the sole
purpose of attacking America's president
which will weaken our country on the
national stage do you believe that
Vladimir Putin is sitting in his office
right now in the Kremlin laughing and
what those on the other side of the
aisle are doing and believing that those
on the other side of the aisle are
useful idiots helping objection I have a
point of order an old lady was stated
point of order I have a point of order
according to the rules and the rules of
this committee the house rules we cannot
attribute derogatory names to our
colleagues or motives to our colleagues
and I believe the gentleman said those
on the other side of the aisle or idiots
this is a very sacred and somber
responsibility I've taken an oath of
office my good friend just like you did
I am concerned about the Constitution
just as you are and I would not engage
in any behavior that could be described
as idiot never in my life or my
colleagues have we ever discussed
behaving like idiots mr. chairman that
is an inappropriate terminology and
description of the members of this house
or Republicans or Democrats no matter
what position I will
overruled I will overrule the point of
order the rules of the quorum refer to
motive quoting someone an idiot is not
flat
but it does not go to motive and I
believe we should have the mobile the
most robust debate I believe we should
respect each other but I don't think we
should but I don't think that goes to
motive and accordingly I'm going to
overrule the ruin at the point of order
proceed Thank You mr. chairman action I
didn't call anybody an idiot I said
useful idiot and secondly I asked the
witness whether he believed that as part
of Vladimir Putin's strategy he radomir
Putin was being aided by useful idiots
in America your answer sir you know
congressman I can't be sure to the
motives of Vladimir Putin or the
Russians who want to interfere with our
election process in 2016 but I can't be
certain of one thing Donald Trump is a
private citizen at the time and he had
no more responsibility or authority to
secure the integrity of the 2016
election cycle than I did that
responsibility fell to the intelligence
community and the obama-biden
administration they clearly failed never
did they contact under my tenure
Meeta inform of inform me or anyone of
the campaign at the time of any
potential hacking which may have been
transpiring never did they contact us to
alert us of any potential security
violations as it related to the election
and so I think mr. Comey mr. Brennan and
mr. clapper ultimately owned the
responsibilities ahead of the
intelligence community to understand why
they did not do a better job of
protecting the American electorate in
2016 to ensure we didn't have foreign
interference and and mr. Lewandowski had
they contacted you what would be been
your response in terms of notifying
others on the election in terms of their
dealing with Russians we would have
worked with them I would have
recommended working through Council to
work with them to notify them of any
potential contacts which I don't ever
recall having but if we would have had
any Oh to make sure we notified the
appropriate authorities immediately
thank you are you back gentleman yields
back the gentleman from Florida Thank
You mr. chairman mr. Lewandowski I just
want to follow up on mr. Johnson the
mullah reported volume to page 9 he says
one month later this is a month after
your June
meaning presumably after you returned
from vacation the president met again
with Lewandowski followed up on the
request to have sessions limit the scope
of the Russia investigation
just to clarify that he did do that but
I want to go back to that meeting on
June 19th the president asked you to
write down word-for-word a script that
he wanted the Attorney General of the
United States to deliver isn't that
correct I'm sorry can you just give me
the reference again congressman well let
me do this previously you testified
because it's reported in the malla
report that the president asked
Lewandowski to deliver a message to
sessions and write this down this is
page 91 this was the first time the
president asked him to take dictation
you wrote as fast as possible the notes
that you took of that meeting are on the
screen if you could I don't know that
the note sorry I'm gonna I'm gonna read
the read the section of the notes that
you took that were again this is what
you were asked to deliver to the
Attorney General the United States to
announce in public I know I recuse
myself from certain things having to do
with specific areas but our POTUS is
being treated very unfairly he shouldn't
have a special prosecutor counsel
because he has he hasn't done anything
wrong I was on the campaign with him for
nine months there were no Russians
involved with him I know for a fact
because I was there he didn't do
anything wrong
except to run the greatest campaign in
American history that's from page 91
that's again that's what President Trump
wanted the Attorney General to say in
public about the special counsels
investigation right I believe that's an
accurate representation so this is in
June of 2017 you said that you didn't
know about you didn't know about the
Attorney General being barred from
participating speaking out about the
Russian investigation the public didn't
know about all these attempts to
influence the investigation at that time
but what we did know what everyone knew
mr. Lewandowski was that the president's
campaign was under investigation and
they knew the Attorney General couldn't
touch it because he was a major part of
the campaign he advised on national
security matters and back in March he
had recused himself he had recused
himself from anything having to do with
the investigation you didn't you weren't
away
of that at all that what he did in March
and the fact that he had recused himself
I was aware of the Attorney General's
recusal and so when the president asked
you to deliver a speech that he wanted
the Attorney General who could not
participate in the investigation
couldn't talk about anything having to
do with the investigation he recused
himself when the president asked you to
deliver that word-for-word speech for
him that there was no inconsistency with
that and the fact that the Attorney
General had recused himself you knew
that he had and you knew that he
couldn't participate in any way I'm not
a trainee congressman I'm not asking as
an attorney I am but that's not how it's
now I'm asking I'm just asking you if
you knew that he had recused himself you
did right I'm aware of the public
reports that Jeff Sessions recused
himself from the investigation by
recusing this off you're aware of the
public reports that and what was in his
his recusal statement on March 2nd of
2017 that he wasn't going to participate
in any existing or future investigations
of any matters relating to the campaign
for president you knew that was out
there so when the president asked you to
specifically go in there and ask him to
deliver a speech which was contrary to
that forget about being a lawyer did it
did it strike you as often anyway were
you concerned in any way no sir
was it the right decision for sessions
to recuse himself well I can't comment
on Jeff Sessions decision-making process
so here's what he here's what he did the
script says a group of people want to
subvert the Constitution I'm going to
meet with the special prosecutor to
explain this is very unfair and let the
special prosecutor move forward with
investigating election mailing for
future elections so that nothing can
happen in future elections he was the
president you'll agree was trying to
force the investigation to focus only on
the future so it didn't focus on him is
that right mr. Lewandowski I don't agree
to that that's not what when you look
only in the future and you're not
allowed to look at the one investigation
into the president that's not how you
interpret that you interpret it
differently I think that could be your
interpretation it is I think it's an
obvious interpretation if we have more
time I'd ask what your is you know what
yours is but I'll just close with this
a month he asked you to do this he
brought you in to talk to you the
Attorney General because the president
was terrified mr. Lewandowski a month
before your meeting the special counsel
was appointed and the president said oh
my god this is terrible he wanted you to
pressure the Attorney General someone
who wasn't even allowed to talk about
the investigation to block him from
looking at his own conduct mr.
Lewandowski that's abuse of power and as
we go on through this investigation I
hope you'll be able to to further
elaborate on how you could haven't seen
this in any other light than the obvious
way the president attempted to abuses
panel radio time is expired the witness
may answer the question thank you a
gentleman from Thank You mr. chairman
mr. Lewandowski welcome to what my
colleagues on the other side of the
aisle have alternative alternatively
described and argued over the past week
as an impeachment inquiry an impeachment
investigation an impeachment probe and
an impeachment proceeding now if you're
confused which one I assure you you're
not alone a lot of the folks that are
watching today might be confused because
they might be thinking that impeachment
proceedings are supposed to be initiated
after a vote by the full House of
Representatives and they'd be right but
you see the Democrats now the party of
impeachment tried that three times and
failed miserably three times twice
before the Muller report and then once
again after the Mullen report so last
week the party of impeachment which is
in charge of this committee changed our
rules so that they could get to
impeachment in a different way and mr.
Lewandowski you're lucky you're the
first witness for the party of
impeachments new impeachment procedure I
feel very lucky thank you you should now
I know that you've testified before the
house before the Senate and before the
special counsel but in fairness mr.
Lewandowski that's when my colleagues on
the other side of the aisle were
promising the American people that there
was going to be impeachment by collusion
or impeachment by conspiracy which of
course didn't exist in the
special counsel said it didn't exist so
then they had to shift and say well now
it's going to be impeachment by
obstruction of justice remember that
they promised they promised that special
counsel Mulder was going to breathe life
into impeachment by obstruction of
justice but instead he put it to death I
don't know if you remember but I asked
him can you give me an example other
than Donald Trump where the Justice
Department determined that an
investigated person was not exonerated
because their innocence was not
conclusively determined and his answer
was I cannot do you remember that so as
it turns out all 200 nearly 200 pages of
the Muller report and the analysis of in
volume two of obstruction of justice was
done under a legal standard and legal
burden of proof that is not recognized
and ever been used before in American
jurisprudence but the party of
impeachment are gonna gloss over that
today they're also going to gloss over
the fact that the Inspector General
criminally referred the FBI director who
leaked the information to get the
Special Counsel in the first place and
the same inspector general who found
that facts establishing that that same
FBI director was in fact targeting
Donald Trump at the same time in an
investigation where he said he was an
investigating Donald Trump now you might
think that this committee would be
interesting in hearing from that
Inspector General for the first time
rather than hearing from you for the
fourth time but maybe you can be helpful
because the party of impeachment
they don't care mr. Lewandowski what
kind of impeachment you can deliver for
them there 135 Democrats and socialists
in the House of Representatives that
have publicly come out for impeachment
they're in agreement the president needs
to be impeached the problem is they've
come up with more than a dozen different
reasons that they're arguing about are
the basis for that impeachment we've
talked about impeachment by collusion
we've talked about impeachment by
conspiracy we talked about impeachment
by obstruction of justice let's cover a
few more impeachment under the
emoluments clause did the first and only
president rich enough to largely self
fund a successful presidential campaign
ever
admit to you that he secretly ran for
president to get rich no sir
okay he's already very rich did do you
have any information or evidence mr.
Lewandowski about crimes the president
committed for ignoring congressional
subpoenas as a basis of impeachment I do
not
how about dangling pardons do you know
if the President did he ever admit or
say to you that he would pardon anybody
in law enforcement who was trying to
enforce or protect our territorial
borders at the request of the White
House I can't discuss private
conversations that may or may not occur
with the president okay well how about
this one how about impeachment by using
a sharpie on a hurricane weather map did
the president ever admit or say to you
that he intentionally committed an
impeachable high crime by magic marker
as some of my Democratic colleagues are
contending again congressman I can't
discuss any private conversation I may
have had well present I'm sorry your
frankly not being helpful at all mr.
Lewandowski maybe you don't understand
that the party of impeachment they're
not picky at all they don't even care if
you don't have impeachment if you got
anything on Donald Trump how about on
justice Cavanaugh because this morning
now they say they want to impeach
justice Cavanaugh have you got anything
that supports impeachment of justice
Cavanaugh he's a good man
well listen I I know you're disappointed
that you've only been here four times
but don't you think that there isn't
going to be another opportunity because
this committee has become the search
party for impeachment and they're gonna
bring back anybody as much as they have
to to find something anything to keep
this impeachment hopes alive I yield
back
gentleman yields back 15 seconds over
time the lady from California Thank You
mr. chair
mr. Lewandowski I want to follow up from
my colleague here mr. Deutsch it's clear
that the president was desperate for you
to deliver the message to sessions
everyone else had said no and he went to
great lengths to make sure that you'd be
effective in delivering it after the
president dictated the message he told
you to tell the Attorney General that he
would be the most popular
I in the country if he delivered that
message to limit the investigation to
the future is that correct could you
reference me to that in the report
please yes it's in volume 2 page 92 so
is that correct
I'd like to reference so while you're
looking I'm gonna move on so the
president is telling you how to convince
sessions to do it it's page 92 first
paragraph to tell sessions that he'd be
the most popular guy in the country if
he did what the president ordered and
the president picked you for a reason
because he knew that you had the traits
of an enforcer and described yourself as
his quote loyal soldier this was no
exception did you find it now I have it
here too okay so the Attorney General
that he would be the most popular guy in
the country if he delivered that message
do you see that on page 92 I do so is
that correct I believe it's accurate and
you told the president that you
understood what he wanted sessions to do
is that what you told the special
counsel same page and you did understand
what the president wanted he knew not to
create a trail so looking at the slide
Lewandowski wanted to pass the message
to sessions in person rather than on the
phone where is that after you left the
Oval Office you didn't schedule an
official meeting with sessions instead
you called the Attorney General at home
correct
if that's what's in the report you told
sessions you wanted to meet in person
rather than on the phone you could have
just read the message from the president
over the phone but you knew that it
would make hurt harder to persuade
sessions to do what you wanted so you
wanted to meet with him in person's
correct if that's what the report states
yes so the Attorney General works at the
Department of Justice but you told the
special count so that you didn't want to
meet in the Department of Justice
because you knew that if you went into a
government building that there's a
public log of the visit and you
specifically told the special counsel
that you did not want to quote a public
law of your public log of your visit
isn't that right that's accurate so why
is that why didn't you want to leave a
paper trail for your visit well Jeff and
I have friends socially and I want to
have the opportunity to have a meal with
Jeff and relay the conversation which
the president asked me to ask Jeff to
consider giving so if that was the case
then why was there a problem with you
having to do it in secret essentially I
mean it was a very important message you
were delivering from the president and
it was a message that could certainly be
viewed as completely inappropriate
considering that you were not even an
employee of the White House your private
citizen you're delivering a message to
the Attorney General to limit the
investigation so if you didn't think you
were doing anything wrong then why would
it matter that there was a public log I
want to have the opportunity speak with
Jeff in a more relaxed atmosphere and
have a meal with him to have the
conversation well you said that another
reason for not meeting at the DOJ was
because you quote did not want sessions
to have an advantage over you by meeting
on sessions turf is that right that's
right I want to have a private
conversation in a more relaxed
atmosphere so again if this was an
appropriate message to deliver and if it
was just about that why would it matter
whose turf it was on why couldn't you go
to his office you're his friend why
couldn't you go to his office and meet
with him there I suppose I could have
but I chose to have it I wanted to have
a discussion with Jeff as we have had so
many occasions before that
I mean I've never inside the Department
of sessions knew that it was wrong and
the sessions canceled his meeting with
you if you guys were good friends why
would he have bothered to cancel it did
he call you up to reschedule it that'd
be a question for Jeff sessions well
after you testified and you testified
earlier that after the inauguration you
didn't communicate with the Attorney
General often you're a good friend you
have dinner with so when you said that
you had a message to deliver isn't it
fair to say that sessions knew you were
calling on behalf of the President and
then that message was from him I have no
idea what was in Jeff cells minds it to
be clear the Attorney General knew it
was a message from the president and he
still refused to meet with you mr.
Lewandowski is clear to me that sessions
knew what we all know sitting here today
that what you were doing was wrong he
wanted nothing to do with your secret
messages because he knew it was entirely
improper for a private citizen to go
behind the backs of the White House
Counsel and secretly meet with him
somewhere without any record of your
meeting on your turf to try to persuade
the Attorney General to protect the
president from investigation into his
own misconduct well you know you can't
protect him anymore and I'm glad that
this misconduct can finally be brought
to public attention so that the
president can be held accountable the
gentlelady's time has expired
the witness has requested a short recess
the committee will resume in five
minutes the committee stands in recess